This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. If you're like me, you know this feeling. Maybe you're at a party or you're walking down the street and suddenly, out of a sea of passing faces, one of them lights up, looking right at you. This person starts waving, says hello. This person is glad to see you. And you?
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。如果你和我一样，你一定懂这种感觉。也许你在派对上，或者走在街上，突然之间，在擦肩而过的人海中，有一张脸亮了起来，正看着你。这个人开始挥手，向你打招呼。这个人很高兴见到你。而你呢？
You have no idea who you're looking at. And you? You have no idea who you're looking at. Recognizing faces is a crucial skill. But although your mind is amazing at identifying your boyfriend or your child in a crowd, there are important limits to this ability. Some of us, like me, are extremely bad at it. Some of us, like me, are extremely bad at it. Some of us are terrific. Today, we bring you a classic hidden brain episode about people on opposite ends of the facial recognition spectrum. We'll also explore how our ability to recognize faces has broad implications in our lives.
你根本不知道自己在看谁。而你呢？你根本不知道自己在看谁。识别面孔是一项至关重要的技能。但是，尽管你的大脑在人群中识别你的男朋友或孩子时表现得惊人，这种能力却有着重要的局限性。我们中的一些人，比如我，在这方面极其糟糕。我们中的一些人，比如我，在这方面极其糟糕。我们中的一些人则非常厉害。今天，我们为你带来一期经典的“隐藏的大脑”节目，探讨面部识别能力光谱两端的人。我们还将探讨我们识别面孔的能力对我们的生活产生的广泛影响。
And then, in the second part of today's show, we're going to bring you another look at facial recognition from the revisionist history podcast. If you're unfamiliar with the show, revisionist history is best-selling author Malcolm Gladwell's podcast about things overlooked and misunderstood. The show has covered everything from what Americans get wrong about guns to how English muffins get their signature nooks and crannies. It turns out that Malcolm, like me, struggles with recognizing faces. His producer, Lucy Sullivan, on the other hand, is exceptionally good at it. And Lucy wanted to find out what's going on, or isn't going on, in our brains when we see someone we know. She also brings
然后，在今天节目的第二部分，我们将带你从播客节目《修正主义历史》中重新审视面部识别。如果你对这个节目不熟悉，《修正主义历史》是畅销书作家马尔科姆·格拉德威尔的播客，专门讲述那些被忽视和误解的事物。该节目涉猎广泛，从美国人在枪支问题上搞错了什么，到英国玛芬蛋糕是如何形成其标志性的蜂窝状气孔的，无所不包。事实证明，马尔科姆和我一样，在辨认面孔方面也很吃力。另一方面，他的制作人露西·沙利文在这方面却异常擅长。露西想弄清楚，当我们看到认识的人时，我们的大脑里到底发生了什么，或者没有发生什么。她还给我们带来
us stories about suspected super recognizer former president Bill Clinton and how face blindness almost ended a friendship. Stay tuned after today's business history. We'll start with someone whose job requires her to be quick with faces. She's a cop. My name's Alison Young and I'm a police officer in the Metropolitan Police in London. She started out several years ago working on response teams in East London. These are the cops who mostly just respond to 911 calls. Then about three and a half years into that job, she and a bunch of her fellow officers
了关于疑似超级辨脸专家前总统比尔·克林顿的故事，以及面盲症是如何差点毁了一段友谊的。商业历史播客结束后请继续收听。我们将从一个工作需要对人脸反应迅速的人开始。她是一名警察。我叫爱丽森·扬，我是伦敦警察厅的一名警官。几年前，她开始在伦敦东部的应急小组工作。这些警察主要负责响应911报警电话。大约在工作三年半后，她和许多同事
were invited to take a series of tests at a university. You get given like three or four different faces and you have to memorize those faces. Then a new screen appears with other faces. These ones are obscured in some way or heavily pixelated. One of the faces you saw earlier might now show up wearing a beard. So you have to try and work out which one of the faces is the face that you've seen before.
被邀请去一所大学参加一系列测试。你会得到大约三四个不同的面孔，你必须记住这些面孔。然后会出现一个新屏幕，上面有其他面孔。这些面孔以某种方式模糊了，或者进行了严重的像素化处理。你之前看到的一张面孔现在可能会带着胡子出现。所以你必须设法找出哪张面孔是你以前见过的那张。
And it's that kind of thing. The test, of course, was measuring how good officers were at recognizing faces. A while later, Alison received her results. She came in second out of all the officers. And they asked me to come down to Scotland Yard. Scotland Yard, of course, is the headquarters for London police. When she got there she was told she was being added to a new unit they were forming. It was called the Super
诸如此类的事情。当然，这项测试是为了衡量警官们辨认面孔的能力有多强。不久之后，爱丽森收到了她的测试结果。在所有警官中，她名列第二。他们要求我前往苏格兰场。当然，苏格兰场是伦敦警察局的总部。她到那儿后被告知，她将被调入他们正在组建的一个新单位。它被称为超级
Recognizer Unit. Yes that's the name that they've given. Do you feel like a Super Recognizer? Um I don't know I don't um well I guess so but I don't think I'd necessarily say that a lot because it's just the word super isn't it? It just sounds a bit super. I don't know, it's just the notion of the word super kind of brings out as if we're some sort of superhero or something like that, whereas that isn't the case. In other words, don't picture Superman leaping tall buildings in a single bound. Picture instead a bunch of cops sitting in front of computers. Members of the super recognisers unit would be given the faces of criminal suspects and
辨脸小组。是的，这是他们起的名字。你觉得自己是一个超级辨脸专家吗？嗯，我不知道，我不太……嗯，我想是的，但我并不认为我一定会经常这样说，因为“超级”这个词本身就是这样，不是吗？听起来有点太夸张了。我不知道，这个词的概念让人感觉好像我们是什么超级英雄之类的，但事实并非如此。换句话说，不要想象超人一跃跳过高楼大厦。相反，想象一下一群坐在电脑前的警察。超级辨脸小组成员会拿到犯罪嫌疑人的照片，然后
then try, in essence essence to play a matching game well, there's a catalog of criminals essentially that I wanted by police and What they decided to develop was a thing called snapping Which meant that we may not know who that person is, but if I look at this face Number one photo on this on this, and then I continue to go through further and further and further through different photos, can I find him in any other photos that he's wanted for? Which then means that we've got him for one offence of, I don't know, theft, we find him
尝试，本质上就是玩一个配对游戏，好吧，基本上有一个警方通缉的罪犯目录，他们决定开发一个叫做“抓拍”的东西，这意味着我们可能不知道那个人是谁，但如果我看着这张脸，看着这个上面的第一张照片，然后我继续浏览越来越多、越来越多的不同照片，我能在其他任何通缉照片中找到他吗？这就意味着，我们掌握了他的一起犯罪证据，比如说，我不知道，偷窃，我们又发现了
for another offence to do with theft, and you end up accruing this one person for around 25 to 30 different crimes. Allison was also called on to use her facial recognition skills when she was out in the field. In 2015, for example, the Transit Police came to Scotland Yard for help. A 21-year-old woman and two girls aged 15 and 16 complained that a man had inappropriately touched them while riding the bus. Transit police pulled security footage taken from the various buses.
他犯下的另一起与偷窃相关的罪案，最后你就会发现这个人累积了大约25到30起不同的罪行。当爱丽森在外面执勤时，她也被要求运用她的面部识别技能。例如，在2015年，交通警察来到苏格兰场寻求帮助。一名21岁的女子和两名分别为15岁和16岁的女孩投诉说，一名男子在坐公交车时对她们进行不当触摸。交警调取了不同公交车上的安全监控录像。
From the pictures and the witness accounts, it appeared his modus operandi was to get on the bus with a newspaper. He would sit next to the young woman and then attempt to fondle her under cover of the newspaper. And they were overtly young in the respect that some of them were in school uniformed. The security footage was grainy. The Transit Police didn't have an ID on the man.
从照片和证人陈述来看，他的作案手法似乎是拿着一份报纸上车。他会坐在年轻女子旁边，然后试图在报纸的掩护下抚摸她。而且她们显然很年轻，有些甚至还穿着校服。监控录像画面非常模糊。交警没有这个男人的身份证信息。
And because he struck at different times on different buses, they didn't know how to track him down. And they basically had said to us, we need to find this man. It's young girls, it's predatory, etc. So myself and my colleague, Texas Sergeant Elliot Porritt, did some investigation. They studied the security videos, and eventually they figured out which station the man tended to frequent. After a lot of investigation, we discovered that he had quite a specific route of generally being around Camden Town,
而且因为他是在不同的时间、不同的公交车上作案，他们不知道该如何追踪他。他们基本上对我们说，我们需要找到这个人。这是针对年轻女孩的，具有掠夺性，等等。所以我和我的同事、侦探中士埃利奥特·波里特做了一些调查。他们研究了监控视频，最终找出了这个男人经常出没的车站。经过大量调查，我们发现他有一条相当特定的路线，通常在卡姆登镇附近活动，
which is an area in Northwest London. Camden Town is a busy neighborhood. It's heavily populated, with lots of shops and tourists and people always milling about. It's perfect, in other words, for someone to blend into the background. Alison and Elliot Porritt knew what they had to do. So we made our way to Camden Town from Scotland Yard on a Wednesday.
这是伦敦西北部的一个地区。卡姆登镇是一个热闹的街区。这里人口稠密，有许多商店、游客和总是四处闲逛的人。换句话说，这里非常适合某人融入背景。爱丽森和埃利奥特·波里特知道他们必须做什么。于是我们在周三从苏格兰场出发前往卡姆登镇。
I can't remember the exact day, but I know it was a Wednesday. This was supposed to be just a scouting mission to get a sense of the Camden Town bus station. Alison and her partner decided to look through old security footage in the CCTV room. So we went to the CCTV bit which was just behind a clear Perspex glass where people buy their tickets. So it's right by the entrance foyer to the station. Detective Porritt began talking with the transit security. Allison was looking through the glass at the commuters milling about the station.
我不记得具体日期了，但我知道那是星期三。这本应只是一次侦察任务，旨在熟悉卡姆登镇公交车站的情况。爱丽森和她的搭档决定在闭路电视监控室查看旧的监控录像。于是我们去了闭路电视监控室，它就在人们买票的透明有机玻璃后面。所以它就在车站的入口门厅旁。波里特侦探开始与交通安保人员交谈。爱丽森则透过玻璃看着在车站里闲逛的通勤者。
I just glanced up and through the crowd, I just saw him. I saw him walk in, pick up a newspaper and leave. I would go to leave and at which point I, I mean I screamed because I don't know why I did it. I would go to leave and at which point I, I mean I screamed because I don't know why I did it, I just screamed. I don't know, I can't quite work out why but I just made quite a loud noise and just said to Sergeant Poirot he's outside. They both stopped what they were doing and rushed to catch up with the man.
我只是瞥了一眼，透过人群，我一眼就看到了他。我看到他走进来，拿了一份报纸然后离开。我正要离开，就在那时，我——我的意思是，我尖叫了起来，因为我不知道自己为什么要这么做。我正要离开，就在那时，我——我的意思是，我尖叫了起来，因为我不知道自己为什么要这么做，我只是尖叫了。我不知道，我说不清楚为什么，但我只是发出了一声很大的声音，然后对波里特中士说他在外面。他们俩停下手中的活，冲过去追赶那个男人。
But it was quite difficult to get out because we had to go all the way back round, back round to the foyer. So by the time we'd got into the main foyer where he was, we couldn't see him anymore. They ran out of the station to see if he'd left. They looked left, couldn't see him. They looked right. Alison caught a quick glimpse of a man disappearing around a corner. This fraction of a second was all she needed to recognize her target. The cops started running toward a corner. This fraction of a second was all she needed to recognize her target.
但要出去相当困难，因为我们不得不绕回原路，绕回门厅。所以当我们到达他所在的那个主要门厅时，我们已经看不到他了。他们跑出车站，看他是不是已经走了。他们向左看，没看到他。他们向右看。爱丽森瞥见一个男人正飞快地消失在转角处。这短短的一瞬间正是她识别出目标所需要的。警察开始朝着转角跑去。这短短的一瞬间正是她识别出目标所需要的。
The cop started running toward the corner. And as we turned, we looked just behind the wall, he was there. The officers approached the man. As soon as we got up to him, as we face to face with him, the pair of us, myself, Detective Sergeant Porritt, we were 100 million percent certain that this was the exact same gentleman in all the photos.
警察开始朝转角跑去。当我们转过弯时，朝墙后面一看，他就站在那里。警官们走近那个男子。当我们走到他身边，与他面对面时，我们两个人，我和波里特侦探中士，有一千万分之确定，这就是所有照片中那个一模一样的男子。
So he was taken handcuffed immediately and explained to him what he was being arrested for, etc. And it was extremely noticeable that he was very nervous, his mouth just went completely dry and he just wasn't able to speak. When we spoke with Alison Young, she was no longer working on the super recognizer unit. She had gone on to other detective work. But she said the time she spent on this unusual unit was the first she ever realized she had an above-average ability.
于是他立即被戴上手铐带走，并向他解释了他被逮捕的原因等等。非常明显的是，他非常紧张，嘴巴完全干了，一句话也说不出来。当我们采访爱丽森·扬时，她已经不在超级辨脸小组工作了。她已经去从事其他侦探工作了。但她说，她在制作这个不同寻常的小组度过的时间，是她第一次意识到自己拥有高于平均水平的能力。
The thing is, she's still not sure where the skill comes from. Yeah, I think my mum was just like, oh you've got that from me. Modest as ever, my mother. But my mummy is very, very, very good with faces. Very good. We'll be walking, just doing some shopping and she'll see someone and then go and to them. And she'll have known them from primary school and she'll remember them. And my mom's, what is she now, 61? And she went to primary school at like seven or eight with them and she'll remember them.
关键是，她仍然不确定这种技能从何而来。是的，我想我妈妈当时就像是，哦，你这是遗传了我。一如既往地谦虚，我的母亲。不过我妈妈对辨认面孔非常非常厉害。非常厉害。我们一起散步，随便购购物，她看到某个人就会走过去打招呼。而且她会认出那是小学同学，并且能记住他们。我妈妈现在多少岁来着，61岁？她大概七八岁时就和他们一起上小学，她居然能记住他们。
So do you think this is genetic or do you think this is learned? I don't know, I don't think it's learned. I don't think you could teach someone. I don't think you could teach someone to I don't think you could teach someone to be able to just do it at all. Coming up, how common is Alison's skill? Are you a super recognizer? Can you learn to be one? That and more from a scientist who studies how we identify faces. That and more from a scientist who studies how we identify faces.
那你觉得这是基因决定的，还是后天习得的？我不知道，我不认为这是后天习得的。我不认为你可以教别人这个。我不认为你可以教别人去——我不认为你可以教别人完全凭空就能做到这一点。接下来，爱丽森的这种技能有多普遍？你是一个超级辨脸专家吗？你能通过学习成为一个吗？这些以及更多内容，将由一位研究我们如何识别人脸的科学家为您解答。这些以及更多内容，将由一位研究我们如何识别人脸的科学家为您解答。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. So the other week I was at the airport and just like everyone else, I showed my driver's license to get past security. And it occurred to me that I was operating on an assumption that I think is widely shared. I assumed the TSA officer was pretty good at matching my face with the photo on my driver's license. So I asked Mike Burton, he's a professor of psychology at the University of York in the United Kingdom, if that assumption was true. It's not, although it is a very common assumption. Most of us think we're pretty good at recognizing
你收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。上周我在机场，就像其他人一样，我出示了驾照以通过安检。我突然意识到，我的行动基于一个我认为被广泛接受的假设。我以为美国运输安全管理局（TSA）的工作人员很擅长将我的脸与驾照上的照片进行匹配。所以我问了迈克·伯顿，他是英国约克大学的心理学教授，这个假设是真的吗？事实并非如此，尽管这是一个非常普遍的假设。我们大多数人都认为自己很擅长辨认
faces. But when you actually test people out, particularly in the situation where somebody who doesn't know you is checking a photo against you, it turns out people are really bad at this. Interestingly, even professionals are really bad at it. So we did some work with passport officers where we showed that even passport officers find this a very difficult task and are often inaccurate. When I showed my ID at the airport last week, Mike, I handed over the ID and I noticed that the officer looked at the ID first and then looked at my face second.
面孔。但当你真正对人们进行测试时，特别是在一个不认识你的人将照片与你进行核对的情境下，结果证明人们在这方面真的很糟糕。有趣的是，即使是专业人员在这方面也很糟糕。所以我们和护照官员做了一些工作，结果表明，即使是护照官员也发现这是一项非常困难的任务，而且往往不够准确。迈克，上周我在机场出示身份证时，我把身份证递过去，我注意到工作人员先看了身份证，然后才看我的脸。
And I assume there must be some trick to this, that it actually is you're able to make a better connection if you don't actually look at the person's face, that you start with the ID and then look at the face. Is there any truth to that? No, there's all kinds of techniques that the people who do this professionally use. And what's interesting is they all believe themselves to be performing quite well. But when you test them, just like anybody else, they're actually not very accurate at this. It's a little terrifying what you're telling me because you're saying that this thing that
我以为这其中一定有什么窍门，如果你不真正看着这个人的脸，而是从身份证开始看，然后再看脸，实际上能够建立更好的联系。这是真的吗？不，从事这项工作的人使用各种各样的技术。有趣的是，他们都相信自己表现得相当不错。但当你测试他们时，就像其他人一样，他们在这一点上其实并不怎么准确。你告诉我的这些有点吓人，因为你是说我们
we're relying on to keep ourselves safe, to run security systems at airports and other places, that this is a fundamentally bad system? That is exactly what I'm telling you. I think that what's sort of interesting is that we have come to rely on this, but I think we've come to rely on it for an interesting reason. We are fantastic at recognizing faces, those faces of people we know. We can recognize our family and friends across a huge range of conditions, you know, distances, in bad lights, all kinds. But we falsely assume that this means we're quite good at faces in general, and in fact we're not.
依赖它来保证自身安全、运营机场和其他地方安检系统的东西，从根本上来说是一个糟糕的系统？这正是我要对你说的。我觉得有点意思的是，我们已经开始依赖它了，但我认为我们开始依赖它有一个有趣的原因。我们在识别人脸方面非常厉害，特别是那些我们熟悉的人的脸。我们可以在各种各样的条件下认出我们的家人和朋友，你知道的，在不同的距离下，在光线不好的情况下，各种条件都可以。但我们错误地认为，这意味着我们在总体上也很擅长认脸，而事实上并非如此。
Mike can say all this with some degree of confidence because he ran a study to test for it. So we set up this little experiment where we asked people to match pairs of faces. They just have to say, are these two faces the same person or not? Mike and his colleagues ran this experiment in both the United Kingdom and in Australia. In both countries, they selected some faces that were likely to be well known locally, but unlikely to be known globally. Yes, we use what we call B-list celebrities.
迈克能够非常自信地说出这一切，因为他做过一项专门测试这方面的研究。于是我们设计了这个小实验，要求人们匹配成对的面孔。他们只需要回答：这两张脸是同一个人吗？迈克和他的同事在英国和澳大利亚都进行了这项实验。在这两个国家，他们挑选了一些在当地可能广为人知、但在全球范围内不太为人所知的面孔。是的，我们使用了所谓的B级名人。
So we check it out beforehand. But we use people who are known very well by the local population. These are people like you know news readers, local sports people and they tend to be very well known by the local community but not by people internationally. What we find then is that when the UK people are matching UK celebrities, they're really good at it. And they're really poor at matching the Australian celebrities, the people that they don't know. When you look at the Australian students looking at these photos, you find exactly the opposite pattern. They're great at matching Australian celebrities and poor at matching UK celebrities.
所以我们事先进行了核查。但我们使用的是当地民众非常熟悉的人。这些人就像是新闻主播、本地运动员，他们往往被当地社区所熟知，但国际上的人并不认识他们。然后我们发现，当英国人匹配英国名人时，他们真的非常擅长。而他们在匹配澳大利亚名人——那些他们不认识的人时，表现真的很糟糕。当你看到澳大利亚学生看这些照片时，你会发现完全相反的模式。他们非常擅长匹配澳大利亚名人，而在匹配英国名人时则表现糟糕。
So at this point we know that there's nothing in the faces themselves that make them easy or hard to match. It's just in the perceptions of the viewers. So far so good. We know that people are better at matching familiar faces. But what we then ask is, how well do you think other people will do on these faces when we give them the same task?
所以在这一点上，我们知道面孔本身没有任何因素使它们变得容易或难以匹配。这纯粹在于观察者的认知。目前一切顺利。我们知道人们更擅长匹配熟悉的面孔。但我们接着要问的是，当我们把同样的任务交给其他人时，你认为其他人对这些面孔的识别表现会如何？
And what you find is that the UK viewers think other people will find the UK faces easier, the Australian viewers think other people will find the Australian photos easier. That can't both be true. It must be that they are falsely generalizing their own knowledge to other people. You make a very interesting point in the paper,
你会发现，英国的观众认为其他人会觉得英国面孔更容易识别，澳大利亚的观众认为其他人会觉得澳大利亚照片更容易识别。这两者不可能同时为真。一定是因为他们错误地将自己的知识推广到了其他人身上。你在论文中提出了一个非常有趣的观点，
and I was struck by it, which is that in some ways this might be part of a general phenomenon in cognition where we do not fully understand how difficult a task is for someone else to do. And especially when we're good at something, it's very, very difficult for us to anticipate how much harder it could be for somebody else to do the very same task. That's right. It comes up in a number of areas of psychology. Even something simple like general knowledge. If you happen to have read some books about Napoleon and be knowledgeable about Napoleon, you falsely generalize that and assume that other people know more about Napoleon than they actually do. Of course, we all have our own different areas of specialist knowledge and people turn out to be
这让我印象深刻，那就是在某些方面，这可能是认知中普遍现象的一部分，即我们并没有完全理解某项任务对其他人来说有多么困难。尤其是当我们擅长某事时，我们非常非常难以预料，对其他人来说，去做完全相同的任务可能会困难得多。没错。这在心理学的许多领域都有体现。甚至是像常识这样简单的事情。如果你恰好读过一些关于拿破仑的书并且对拿破仑很了解，你就会错误地将其推广，并假设其他人对拿破仑的了解比他们实际知道的要多。当然，我们每个人都有自己不同的专业知识领域，而事实证明，人们在理解这一点并将其推广方面
rather poor at understanding that and being able to generalize it. I'm wondering how good you are at facial recognition? I'm poor. On the tests I'm just a little below average. And has doing these tests and studying this has it has it sort of changed the way you yourself trust yourself or your ability to recognize faces? Well I do now know how poor I am. I certainly would try not to rely on my own ability to do it. But I think that nobody really knew until the last few years just how bad we all are with unfamiliar faces and it's just becoming clear now.
表现得相当糟糕。我想知道你的面部识别能力有多好？我很差。在测试中，我只是略低于平均水平。进行这些测试和研究是否改变了你自己信任自己或自己辨认面孔能力的方式？嗯，我现在确实知道自己有多差了。我当然会尽量不依赖自己在这方面的能力。但我认为，直到最近几年，大家才知道我们对不熟悉的面孔到底有多么不擅长，而这一点现在才刚刚变得明朗。
After the break we talk with someone who, like me, is very bad at recognizing faces. She shares the strategies she's developed to cope in public settings. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Our chronic inability to recognize faces, coupled with our chronic overconfidence in our ability to recognize faces, has big consequences. One place that's especially true is in the criminal justice system, where eyewitness identifications are often central to police investigations.
休息过后，我们将与一位和我一样非常不擅长辨认面孔的人交谈。她将分享她在公共场合应对时所发展出的策略。你收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们长期无法辨认面孔，再加上我们对自身辨认面孔能力的长期过度自信，会产生严重的后果。这种情况尤其明显的一个地方是刑事司法系统，其中目击者的辨认往往是警方调查的核心。
But this issue also shows up in lots of other settings with lower stakes, recognizing colleagues at an office party or a fellow parent at a school meeting. Julie Dorschlack from Washington, D.C. has had this problem for a long time. I've had a lot of uncomfortable situations, forgetting people and have been accused of being a snob or racist or I mean everything. If Alison Young, the cop we heard from earlier, was a super recognizer, you might call Julie face-blind. Her whole life she's been terrible with faces.
但这个问题也出现在许多其他赌注较低的场景中，比如在办公室派对上认出同事，或者在学校家长会上认出其他家长。来自华盛顿特区的朱莉·多施拉克（Julie Dorschlack）长期以来一直有这个问题。我经历过很多尴尬的情况，忘记了别人，还被指责为势利或种族主义，或者说各种各样的话。如果爱丽森·扬（Alison Young）——我们前面听到的那个警察——是一个超级辨脸专家，你可能会称朱莉为面盲。她一辈子对辨认面孔都一窍不通。
When I was in college, you know, you're on a campus, you meet a lot of people all the time and there were people I met for a few minutes at a party or something, a meeting, I don't know, and I'd be on campus, small campus, walking, and I'd walk past them. Didn't think anything of it. Just smile and keep going. And they were offended. I've heard over time people were offended. I got this little reputation of being this snobby person because I didn't greet everybody that I met, or, how are you doing? And I normally would if I knew them, or I thought I knew them.
当我在大学的时候，你知道的，身处校园里，你会一直遇到很多人，有些人我在派对或某个会议上见过几分钟，我不知道，当我在校园里——一个小校园里散步时，我会从他们身边走过。完全没当回事。只是笑笑然后继续走。而他们被冒犯了。我后来听说人们被觉得受到冒犯。我落得了一个势利眼的坏名声，因为我没有向遇到的每个人都打招呼，或者说“你好吗？”如果我认识他们，或者我以为我认识他们，我通常会打招呼的。
Julie's struggles followed her as she left college and entered the working world. I worked for an architecture firm in Philadelphia, and we had to go to a meeting. And I swore after going into the meeting and then coming back, going back into the meeting room, I talked to this guy as if I knew him. He happened to be African-American,
朱莉的挣扎在她离开大学进入职场后依然如影随形。我在费城的一家建筑事务所工作，我们得去开个会。我发誓，在开完会出来后又走回会议室的过程中，我跟一个家伙说话的语气就像我认识他一样。他碰巧是个非裔美国人，
and I was talking to him. He's like, I'm not that man. I said, oh, I'm sorry. I could have sworn. He's like, oh, okay. So it became that. And it's not people of just color or different ethnicity. What do you do about it?
我在跟他说话。他说：“我不是那个人。”我说：“哦，对不起。我敢发誓……”他说：“哦，好吧。”事情就变成了这样。而且这不仅限于有色人种或不同族裔的人。你对此有什么办法吗？
I apologize profusely, and usually the people just walk away from me. So I just stop. I just feel embarrassed. I'm just used to being embarrassed. Research suggests, by the way, that people are worse at recognizing faces of people from unfamiliar groups.
我连连道歉，通常人们就会直接走开。所以我只能停下来。我只觉得很尴尬。我已经习惯了尴尬。顺便说一句，研究表明，人们对不熟悉群体中人们的面孔识别能力更差。
Many Americans are worse at recognizing the face of someone from a different race than a face of someone from their own race. Now what makes Julie's dilemma especially acute is her husband, Marty. When I look at somebody, I never forget their face. If I spend about 30 seconds looking at somebody, I will remember their face for years and years and years. Marty Dorschlag, Julie's husband, is a super recognizer. For years, Julie's been keenly aware
许多美国人对辨认不同种族的人脸的能力，要比辨认自己种族的人脸差。现在，让朱莉的困境尤为严峻的是她的丈夫马蒂。当我看着某个人时，我永远不会忘记他们的脸。如果我花大约30秒钟看着某个人，我会记住他们的脸好多年好多年。马蒂·多施拉克（Marty Dorschlag），朱莉的丈夫，是一个超级辨脸专家。多年来，朱莉一直深深地意识到
of her husband's superpower. One time they were in Las Vegas sitting down for dinner at a restaurant. Marty glanced up at the waiter. He's like, oh, you waited on me in Columbus, Ohio, an X year, the guy just froze. And then he's like, oh, yeah, and I don't know how you put it together. You named the restaurant, the time, the place. And it was probably 15 years before. And he said, yeah, you're right.
她丈夫的这种超能力。有一次他们在拉斯维加斯的餐厅坐下来吃晚饭。马蒂瞥了一眼服务员。他说：“哦，你在俄亥俄州哥伦布市接待过我，在某某年。”那家伙直接愣住了。然后他说：“哦，对，天哪。”我不知道你是怎么把这些拼凑起来的。你连餐厅、时间和地点都说出来了。那可能已经是15年前的事了。那服务员说：“对，没错。”
And so he does it a lot with servers, and I think people in the restaurant industry travel, and he remembers them because they're servers. You see their face. Marty's had lots of encounters like this. Like at the Dallas airport, he spotted a man he sat behind at a University of Michigan football game three years earlier. Now, you might think that with this gift,
所以他经常对服务员这样做，我想餐饮业的人到处跑，而他能记住他们，因为他们是服务员。你能看到他们的脸。马蒂有过很多这样的遭遇。比如在达拉斯机场，他认出了三年前在密歇根大学一场橄榄球赛上坐在他身后的一名男子。现在，你可能会认为有了这个天赋，
Marty could at least be Julie's crutch, but it doesn't always work out like that. If we're in a place I'll always sometimes and I whisper in the back of her ear that's Jim you know who works at so-and-so. Well sometimes he doesn't catch me in time I think we were at one of your friend's apartments a guy came in and I went up and hugged him and said oh it's so good to see you again. And Marty's friend leaned over and said, why is Julie hugging the caterer? So, yeah. I remember that too. And I, and I thought that was funny. I saw it coming too.
马蒂至少可以成为朱莉的拐杖，但事情并不总是这样的。如果我们在一个地方，我有时会凑到她耳边小声说，那是吉姆，你知道的，在某某公司工作的那个。嗯，有时他没能及时提醒我，我想我们当时在你的某个朋友的公寓里，一个男人走进来，我走过去拥抱了他，说：“哦，很高兴再次见到你。”马蒂的朋友靠过来小声说：“为什么朱莉要拥抱餐饮服务人员？”所以，是的。我也记得那一幕。而且我，而且我觉得这挺搞笑的。我也预料到会这样。
I saw Julie approaching the guy and I said to my friend, I said, watch, she's going to think that's your roommate. Cause they look sort of, they looked, I mean, they had the same color hair, I think, or something. And they were the same size on the, and I said to him, here it comes, watch. And sure enough, she did it. It was. But I touched him, I hugged him.
我看到朱莉朝那个人走去，我对我的朋友说：“看着吧，她会以为那是你的室友。”因为他们长得有点像，他们看起来——我的意思是，我觉得他们头发颜色一样，或者类似的东西。而且他们在体型上也差不多，我对他说：“来了，看着吧。”果不其然，她真的这么做了。确实。但我碰了他，我拥抱了他。
So that goes into another. You have to be careful. Julie's cringeworthy ordeals hit close to home. Recently, I was watching a play. The lead actor looked familiar. I stared at his face for the better part of 90 minutes, but it took me until after the play was over to realize this was a colleague of mine from NPR. I'd be absolutely terrible as a TSA agent.
所以这就牵涉到另一个问题。你必须小心谨慎。朱莉那些令人尴尬的经历就发生在身边。最近，我在看一出戏剧。男主角看起来很面熟。我盯着他的脸看了差不多90分钟，直到演出结束后，我才意识到这是我在NPR的一位同事。如果去当TSA（美国运输安全管理局）安检员，我绝对会一塌糊涂。
And it got me wondering, are there any solutions here? Julie's picked a simple one. I don't approach people with as much joie de vivre. I don't touch them until I'm sure they want to be touched and or that I know them. And also, I sort of create this verbal cue for them to tell me why I know them. So if I shake their hand, I'll, oh right, do I know you from somewhere? And they're like, if they say, I don't think so, I said, okay, you just looked a little familiar. I'd rather err on that side than not knowing them. And if they finish the sentence, I said, yes, that's right, good to see you again. But I don't use again until I know that they've filled in the blank. There are going to be outliers among us, people with extraordinary skill at recognizing faces.
这让我不禁思考，这里有什么解决办法吗？朱莉选择了一个简单的办法。我不再带着那么多的生活热情去接近别人。在确保别人希望被接触和/或我确实认识他们之前，我不会去触碰他们。此外，我还会为他们创造一个语言线索，让他们告诉我为什么我认识他们。所以如果我和他们握手，我会说：“哦对了，我是不是在哪里见过你？”如果他们说：“我想没有吧，”我说：“好的，你看起来有点面熟。”我宁愿犯这种错误，也不愿装作认识他们。如果他们顺着话头接下去，我说：“是的，没错，很高兴再次见到你。”但在他们把空白填上之前，我绝不说“再次”。在我们当中总会有一些异类，那些在辨认面孔方面有着非凡技能的人。
Some of them end up as security officers, or gregarious socialites, or politicians. The rest of us are going to keep smiling awkwardly at office parties at people we are supposed to know. It's what happens when you stumble around in the 21st century with a mind that was designed in the Stone Age. After the break, revisionist history brings us another take on facial recognition and how it colors so many of our perceptions about ourselves and each other. You don't want to miss it.
他们中的一些人最终成了安保人员、热情洋溢的社会名流或政客。而我们其余的人将继续在办公室派对上，对着那些我们本该认识的人露出尴尬而不失礼貌的微笑。当你带着一个在石器时代设计的大脑在21世纪跌跌撞撞地前行时，就会发生这种事。休息过后，《修正主义历史》将为我们带来关于面部识别的另一种视角，以及它如何影响了我们对自我和彼此的诸多看法。你一定不想错过。
Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. For the rest of today's show, we're bringing you a story from our friends at the Revisionist History podcast. I'll pass things now to Revisionist History host Malcolm Gladwell. Hello, hello. Malcolm Gladwell here. Today, I'm in the studio with my producer, Lucy Sullivan. Lucy? Hi, Malcolm Gladwell here. Today I'm in the studio with my producer Lucy Sullivan. Lucy? Hi Malcolm. I understand you have a story for me about a particular misunderstanding.
请继续收听。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在今天节目的剩余时间里，我们将为您带来来自我们的朋友——《修正主义历史》播客的一个故事。现在我将把话语权交给《修正主义历史》的主持人马尔科姆·格拉德威尔。哈喽，哈喽。我是马尔科姆·格拉德威尔。今天，我和我的制作人露西·沙利文一起在录音室里。露西？嗨，我是马尔科姆·格拉德威尔。今天我和我的制作人露西·沙利文一起在录音室里。露西？嗨，马尔科姆。我听说你有一个关于某个特定误解的故事要讲给我听。
That is true. We're here because I want to tell you about something I'm calling the Missy Incident. It totally changed the way that I think about something foundational and it also reminded me of you. Of me? Of you. Oh my god. think about something foundational, and it also reminded me of you. Of me? Of you.
千真万确。我们来到这里是因为我想告诉你一件事，我称之为“密西事件”。它彻底改变了我对某些基础事物的看法，它也让我想起了你。想起我？想起你。哦天哪。对某些基础事物的看法，它也让我想起了你。想起我？想起你。
Oh my god. Where are we? Okay. So it all happened at this coffee shop that I go to all the time. Can you tell me what the name of the coffee shop is? Malcolm, I can tell you the name of the coffee shop off mic, but my fellow cafe goers did not want me to name it on this podcast because it's that good. Oh, it's that good?
哦天哪。我们在哪儿？好吧。这一切都发生在我经常去的那家咖啡店里。你能告诉我那家咖啡店叫什么名字吗？马尔科姆，我可以在麦克风外告诉你咖啡店的名字，但我同去的咖啡馆顾客们不想让我在这个播客里说出它的名字，因为它实在太棒了。哦，它有那么好吗？
Yeah, it's so good and it's the kind of place that's always packed, so you have to be comfortable sitting with a stranger if you want to get a seat. And that's where this all starts. So the person at the center of this, her name is Missy Kurzweil. She was fresh off of maternity leave with her second kid when the incident happened. I think one of the things that happens when you have a baby and are on maternity leave is like you lose a bit of your identity and yourself. You're spending all your time with a newborn who can't talk back to you.
是的，它太棒了，而且那是一个总是挤满人的地方，所以如果你想找个座位，就得习惯和陌生人拼桌。这就是这一切的开端。所以事件中心的那个人，她的名叫密西·库兹韦尔（Missy Kurzweil）。事情发生时，她刚休完生第二个孩子的产假。我想，当你生了孩子并休产假时发生的一件事就是，你会失去一部分自我认同和真实的自己。你把所有时间都花在一个不会跟你顶嘴的新生儿身上。
And so I was sort of just navigating that transition and wanting human interaction. So Missy is looking for a place to work outside of her home office and she finds this coffee shop. On her third morning kind of feeling out this place is this where a place to work outside of her home office, and she finds this coffee shop. On her third morning, kind of feeling out this place, is this where she wants to set up camp for her HQ. She sits down at this table and in walks this guy, and he's like, hey, you mind if I sit here? She says, sure.
所以我只是在摸索那种转变，并渴望人与人之间的互动。所以密西正在寻找一个可以在家办公之外工作的地方，她找到了这家咖啡馆。在她连续第三天感受这个地方——这真的是一个适合在家办公之外工作的地方吗？她找到了这家咖啡馆。在她连续第三天感受这个地方，看看这是否是她想建立自己大本营的地方时，她在一个桌子旁坐下，这时走进来一个家伙，他说：“嘿，介意我坐这儿吗？”她说：“请便。”
This is JJ Good. So JJ and Missy are sitting down together. What happens? Missy's on the phone with her kids' pediatrician, and JJ is sitting there eavesdropping, and the doctor asks for what's the patient's name, and Missy says, oh, his name's Remy. And JJ freaked out because he was like, you have a Remy? Because I have a Remy.
这位是JJ·古德。所以JJ和密西坐在一起。发生了什么？密西正在给孩子的儿科医生打电话，而JJ坐在那里偷听，医生问患者的名字叫什么，密西说：“哦，他叫雷米。”JJ吓了一跳，因为他说：“你有个叫雷米的孩子？因为我也有一个叫雷米的孩子。”
And then, of course, then we were off to the races. Turns out they both have cats named Sunny. They both are freelancers. He's a cookbook writer. She's also a writer. So for me, it was like on many levels was just really kind of a special bond instantly. And I don't know if this is normal for you, but like I don't usually I'm not usually chatting it up with people at the coffee shop.
然后，当然，我们就一发不可收拾了。结果发现他们俩的猫都叫桑尼（Sunny）。他们都是自由职业者。他是食谱作家。她也是作家。所以对我和来说，在很多层面上，这就像是一种瞬间结下的特殊纽带。我不知道这对你来说是否正常，但我通常不会——我通常不会在咖啡馆里跟别人闲聊。
But these two and there's nothing romantic going on here. Nothing romantic. Strictly friends who are just like, wow, we have so much in common. I think no matter where you're at in your life, meeting someone like JJ feels unusual because he's just so open and so seemingly genuinely interested in what you have to say and what are all these details about your life. So Missy is excited. She goes home and she tells her husband, oh my gosh,
但这两人——这里面没有任何浪漫的事情发生。绝对没有浪漫。纯粹是朋友，他们只是觉得，哇，我们有这么多共同点。我想无论你人生处于什么阶段，遇到像JJ这样的人都会觉得很不寻常，因为他表现得如此坦诚，而且看起来似乎真的对你要说的话以及你生活中的所有这些细节都充满兴趣。所以密西很兴奋。她回到家告诉她丈夫：“哦天哪，
I've met this great friend and I found this great coffee shop to work. Like things couldn't be better. And so for the next few days, Missy and JJ sit together, work together, crucially always at the same spot in the front. But one day she comes in and their usual table is taken. So she just heads to a different one in the back. And maybe an hour after I sat down, I see JJ kind of walk to the back
我遇到了这个超棒的朋友，而且我找到了一个极好的咖啡馆工作。事情简直不能更完美了。”所以在接下来的几天里，密西和JJ坐在一起，一起工作，关键是总是在前面的同一个座位。但有一天她来到店里，他们习惯坐的位子被占了。所以她只能去后面找了张别的桌子。在我坐下大约一个小时后，我看到JJ朝后面走过来，
and he's looking around seemingly for a table and we make direct eye contact. And I start to say, hey, JJ, but he looks at me and sort of kind of registers it and turns around and walks the other way. He ghosts her. He ghosts her. He ghosts her. Like, completely, like, she was like, we made eye contact.
他环顾四周，似乎在找座位，我们目光直接交汇了。我刚想说：“嘿，JJ，”但他看了我一眼，似乎认出了我，然后转过身朝另一个方向走去。他甩了她。他甩了她。他甩了她。就好像彻底地……她当时想：“我们明明眼神对视了。
I was like, maybe he didn't see me, but no. He saw me. Our eyes locked. I went to wave. He turned around. So now Missy's like, what is going on here? Like, she had just met his wife a couple days before, and she's like, maybe the wife wasn't comfortable with, like, or maybe she's thinking something's going on. Maybe I said something weird to him.
我想：‘也许他没看到我’，但不是的。他看到我了。我们的视线锁定了。我正要去挥手。他转过身去了。”所以现在密西心里想：“这到底是怎么回事？”就在几天前她还刚见过他的妻子，她在想，也许他的妻子对这个不太舒服，或者她在想是不是有什么事情正在发生。也许我对他说过什么奇怪的话。
Like, she's really like spinning her wheels. She's reeling. She's reeling. And I went back the next day, sat in the back and the same thing happened where he walks by, sort of sees me, seemingly like we make eye contact. And this time, I think I probably was a little bit more reserved because of what had happened the day before. And he turns around and walks the other way again. And now I'm like, okay, I think I might've said something that offended him. My name is Malcolm Gladwell. You're listening to Revisionist History, my podcast about things overlooked and misunderstood. And since we're talking
她真的脑子里转个不停。她心乱如麻。她心乱如麻。第二天我又去了，坐在后面，同样的事情发生了，他走过，看了我一眼，好像我们对视了。这一次，因为前一天发生的事情，我想我可能稍微收敛了一点。他又转过身去，朝另一个方向走开了。现在我想：“好吧，我想我可能说了什么冒犯他的话。”我是马尔科姆·格拉德威尔。你正在收听《修正主义历史》，这是我的播客，专门探讨那些被忽视和误解的事物。既然我们在谈论
about misunderstandings, whatever you think is going on in this story right now, I promise you, you've got it wrong. So, Missy is obviously super bummed about this. You know, I mean, listen, I've been with my husband for a long time, so I haven't been like on the dating scene, but it definitely had an equivalent, like, you put yourself out there and you, like, are, you know, think that you're connecting with someone, but they're not experiencing that same thing. She considered trying to find a new place to work, but like I said, the coffee shop is just too good.
误解，无论你现在觉得这个故事里发生了什么，我向你保证，你都猜错了。所以，密西显然为此感到非常沮丧。你知道的，我的意思是，听着，我和我丈夫在一起很长时间了，所以我一直没有经历过约会场景，但这绝对有异曲同工之妙，就像你展现出真实的自己，然后你，你知道的，以为你正在和某人建立连接，但他们并没有经历那种相同的感受。她曾考虑过找一个新地方工作，但就像我说的，这家咖啡馆实在太棒了。
And so after a few days, she decides, you know what, I'm just gonna go back, I'm gonna ignore the weirdness. And this time, their usual spot in the front is open. So she sits down, and then right on cue, JJ walks in. And he sees me, and his face lights up, and he's like, Missy, you haven't been here
所以在几天后，她决定，不管怎样，我还是要回去，我要忽略那种怪异感。这一次，他们在前面的老座位是空着的。所以她坐了下来，然后就像算准了时间一样，JJ走了进来。他看到我，他的脸亮了起来，他说：“密西，你已经有一两周没来这儿了。
in like a week or two. I've missed you, where have you been? And then he sits down and he's chit chatting and he's catching up and he's asking questions just like nothing, no time passed. Like nothing happened. Like absolutely nothing happened. Yeah.
我想你了，你去哪儿了？”然后他坐下来开始闲聊，叙旧，并像什么都没发生过一样提问，就好像时间没有流逝过一样。就像什么都没发生过。就像绝对什么都没发生过一样。是的。
And I was so confused. I did not know what to make of that, but I was kind of just relieved that the freeze out was over, and so I just went with it and was like, oh, you know, good to see you again. And I just sort of picked up where we left off and I didn't say anything. And it wasn't too long after that, that she discovered what was really going on and why it seemed like this new friend was just totally ignoring her. I'm sitting at a table with JJ and a woman walks in, super friendly, comes over to JJ and says,
我当时非常困惑。我不知道该作何感想，但我多少松了一口气，因为这种冷落终于结束了，所以我顺其自然地说：“哦，你知道的，很高兴再次见到你。”我只是从我们中断的地方继续聊下去，什么也没说。没过多久，她就发现了真相，以及为什么这个新朋友看起来会完全无视她。我正和JJ坐在一张桌子旁，一个女人走了进来，超级热情，走到JJ身边说：
"'Hey, JJ,' and I think goes to give him a hug and ask some questions about how his kids are. Their conversation lasts just a few minutes and then she walks away to get a coffee. And he looks at me and he goes, I don't know who that is. And I was like, what? You seemed like you were friends with her. And he was like, I have this face blindness thing. It gives me a lot of anxiety because I'm probably supposed to know her.
“‘嘿，JJ，’我想她是去给他一个拥抱，并问了一些关于他孩子的情况。”他们的对话只持续了几分钟，然后她就走开去买咖啡了。他看着我说道：“我不知道那是谁。”我当时想：“什么？你看起来像是她的朋友。”他回答说：“我有面盲症。这让我非常焦虑，因为我大概应该认识她。”
And then I think I paused and I said something like, is that why you broke up with me six months ago? like, is that why you broke up with me six months ago? And this is the part that made me think of you, Malcolm, face blindness. Because I've heard that you also might be a little face blind yourself. Yes, yes, that's true. This happens to me all the time.
然后我想我停顿了一下，说了一句类似于：“这就是你六个月前甩了我的原因吗？”就像是，这就是你六个月前甩我的原因吗？这就是让我想起你的地方，马尔科姆，面盲症。因为我听说你可能自己也稍微有点面盲。是的，是的，确实如此。这种事我经常遇到。
I won't remember if I need to be exposed to a face, a person on multiple occasions before their face becomes meaningful or even there. I don't know whether their face is becoming meaningful or that I'm developing so many other ways of recognizing them that I'm feel on safer ground. Like you're not just going to remember someone that you've met once or twice in passing. No, there's no chance that I will. I had, it's actually funny,
我不记得自己是否需要与一张脸、同一个人接触多次，才能让这张脸变得有意义，甚至留在记忆里。我不知道是他们的脸变得有意义了，还是我开发出了其他很多认出他们的方式，让我觉得心里更踏实。就像你不会仅仅因为在一两次擦肩而过中见过某人，就记住对方一样。不，我绝无可能记住。其实挺搞笑的，
because I was sitting in my favorite coffee shop and I see this guy who runs the wine shop across the street. His name is Michael. I know Michael for years. And I see Michael, or I think it's Michael, and I see a slender man in his 50s, about five nine with glasses and a baseball cap, across the street from the wine shop,
因为我当时正坐在我最喜欢的咖啡馆里，看到街对面那家葡萄酒商店的老板。他叫迈克尔。我认识迈克尔好多年了。我看到了迈克尔，或者说我认为那是迈克尔，我看到街对面葡萄酒商店的那个方向，有一个身材苗条、50多岁、身高约五英尺九英寸、戴着眼镜和棒球帽的男子，
and I think, oh, that's gotta be Michael. And I go, Michael! And the guy looks at me like really weird, and he comes over, and he was like, my nightmare is like, oh my God, no, it's not. It's just another dude who's in town who looks a lot like Michael. But that was, my system failed. Uh-huh. It's very rare for me's in town who looks a lot like Michael. But that was my system failed.
我心想，哦，那肯定就是迈克尔。于是我喊道：“迈克尔！”那家伙用非常奇怪的眼神看着我，然后走了过来，他说——我的噩梦就是——哦天哪，不，根本不是。那只是城里另一个长得很像迈克尔的家伙。但那是——我的系统崩溃了。嗯哼。我很少——城里另一个长得很像迈克尔的家伙。但那是我的系统崩溃了。
It's very rare for me to risk it like that. But I risked it because I thought if Michael thinks, I had the reverse JJ, if Michael thinks I'm ignoring him, then that's really bad because I go to the wine shop all the time and I like Michael. See, it's interesting because this never happens to me. Like I'm often on the other side of it being like, all right, I'm just going to pretend like I don't know this person. You always remember.
我很少会冒这样的大险。但我冒险了，因为我想，如果迈克尔觉得——我遭遇了杰杰的反向情况——如果迈克尔觉得我在无视他，那可就太糟了，因为我经常去那家葡萄酒商店，而且我很喜欢迈克尔。你看，这很有意思，因为这种事从不会发生在我身上。我经常处于相反的立场，心想：好吧，我还是假装我不认识这个人吧。你总是能记住。
I always remember. And I always remember people who are completely insignificant to me, like, not in any sort of, like, value judgment way. It's just like, oh, I met you once at my friend's party four years ago, and now you are standing next to me in line at Target. That's so completely foreign. Yeah. And this is why actually Malcolm, to be honest, like when I had first heard, I think I heard from someone in passing before we
我总是能记住。而且我总是能记住那些对毫无意义的人，比如，这绝不是出于什么价值判断。就好像是：哦，四年前我在朋友的派对上见过你一次，现在你正站在Target超市的队伍里挨着我。这对我来说太陌生了。是的。说实话，马尔colm，这就是为什么当我第一次听到——我想我是从某个路人口中听说的，在我们
started working together, like, oh Malcolm, he's face-blind, he has trouble recognizing people. And I was like, okay, like yeah, he's face-blind. Like because I was thinking like, I've never forgotten, I just don't forget people's faces. So I was like, if I were you and I just don't forget people's faces. So I was like, if I were you and I was meeting a million people all the time and people recognized me from book covers, that would be kind of a disorienting experience and it would be kind of nice to have an excuse like,
开始合作之前——听到有人说：“哦，马尔colm，他有面部失认症，他认人有困难。”当时我想，好吧，好吧，他有面部失认症。因为我想象的是：我从来没忘过，我就是不会忘记别人的脸。所以我想，如果换作是我，而我又不断地遇到无数的人，人们还会从书封上认出我，那将会是一种相当混乱的体验，而且能有个借口感觉会挺不错的，
oh, I don't remember you because I'm like face-blind or whatever. But I just couldn't believe that that was true until I heard the story. Yeah, no, no, I do. And it makes me feel bad because I, we're in a, I no, I do. And it makes me feel bad because I feel for JJ because you're in this constant state of worry about that you're going to be perceived as cold or aloof and you're not.
比如“哦，我不记得你了，因为我有面部失认症什么的”。但我简直不敢相信这是真的，直到我听说了这个故事。不，不，我真的有。这让我觉得很内疚，因为我——我们正处于一个——不，我真的有。这让我觉得很内疚，因为我能感同身受杰杰的处境，你总是处于一种持续的焦虑状态中，担心自己会被人视为冷漠或高傲，而你明明不是那样的人。
Yeah, and so this perception problem is exactly what fascinates me about face blindness, which I've now spent way too many hours learning about after hearing this story of Missy and JJ. Because I've always thought that being able to recognize someone was about, you know, having a good or a bad memory, whatever that means. Or just frankly caring enough to remember them. Like, you worry that you might be perceived as cold or aloof
是的，所以这种感知问题正是最让我着迷的面部失认症，在听了米西和杰杰的故事后，我已经花了太多个小时去了解它。因为我一直以为，能够认出某人取决于，你知道的，拥有好记性还是坏记性，不管这意味着什么。或者坦白说，取决于你是否足够在乎去记住他们。就像，你担心自己会被视为冷漠或高傲，
if you don't say hi to Michael, or Missy thought her new friend was ignoring her. I seem to remember way more faces than I want to. I really wanted to understand what's actually going on in our brains when all this happens. After the break, Lucy Sullivan takes us behind the face and into the brain. JJ Goode, Missy's friend from the coffee shop, doesn't know exactly when he realized he had a problem with faces. He just kept having these strange experiences. This one time when he ran into a woman on the train,
如果你不跟迈克尔打招呼的话，或者米西以为她的新朋友在故意无视她。我似乎能记住比我想要的还要多的脸。我真的很想弄明白，当这一切发生时，我们的大脑里到底在进行什么活动。中场休息过后，露西·沙利文将带我们深入面部背后的科学，探究大脑的奥秘。杰杰·古德，米西在咖啡馆认识的朋友，并不知道自己究竟是什么时候意识到自己在认脸方面有问题的。他只是不断经历这些奇怪的事情。有一次他在火车上遇到一个女人，
and he knew he was supposed to know who she was, but he had no idea. We had this conversation where I was like, how is everything? Things are good with me. I didn't mention any, there's no specifics because I wanted to make, I didn't want it. If you walked in and someone had no idea who you were, you would feel bad about yourself. JJ said he also realized something was off when he'd watch movies and TV shows.
他知道自己本该认出她是谁，却完全一头雾水。我们当时有这样一段对话，我说：“最近一切都好吗？”我一切都好。我没有提任何细节，没有任何具体内容，因为我想确保——我不想这么做。如果你走进一个地方，而某人完全不知道你是谁，你心里肯定会不好受。杰杰说，他还发现当自己看电影和电视节目时，有些地方不对劲。
He'd sometimes completely miss a big plot point. When my wife and I are watching a show, I'll be like, who's that guy? And she's like, it's the main character. He just has a hat on. Like it's literally Robert De Niro from the other scene. And I was like, ooh, this is kind of strange. All of this has led to many awkward situations and it's made JJ very aware of other people's feelings.
他有时会完全错过一个重要的情节。当我和妻子一起看节目时，我会问：“那家伙是谁？”她会说：“那是主角啊。他只是戴了顶帽子而已。”就像那明明是罗伯特·德尼罗在另一个场景里的扮相。当时我就想：噢，这可真是有点奇怪。所有这一切导致了许多尴尬的场面，也让杰杰对别人的感受变得异常敏感。
What happened with Missy still haunts him. I am afraid that I might have an interaction with someone and I might not recognize them and I might not recognize them and I might not give them the attention that makes them feel good. It's worth noting that JJ himself is easy to spot. He was born with one arm. Walking around with one arm, you are highly recognizable.
米西身上发生的那件事至今仍萦绕在他的心头。我害怕自己与某人互动时可能会认不出他们，我可能会认不出他们，也可能无法给予他们那种能让他们感到快乐的关注。值得一提的是，杰杰本人其实非常显眼。他出生时就只有一只手臂。带着一只手臂走来走去，你的辨识度极高。
It's like, how many one-armed people do you meet? Probably not a lot. So everybody comes in to the coffee shop and if you see me, you probably will recognize me as that guy from the coffee shop the next day. But I don't recognize a lot of the people who come in. A while back, JJ told some friends about these weird moments he'd always had not recognizing people. And they asked if he'd ever heard of face blindness.
这就好比，你平时能遇到几个独臂的人？大概不多吧。所以每个人走进咖啡馆，如果你看到我，第二天你很可能会认出我就是咖啡馆里的那个家伙。但我却认不出很多走进来的人。不久前，杰杰向一些朋友讲述了这些他一直经历的、认不出人的怪异时刻。他们问他是否听说过面部失认症。
They said Oliver Sacks, the science writer, had it too. And that's when it clicked for JJ. So it is a little bit of the stealth disorder. I mean, people only kind of learn they have it often when they are subjected to a whole bunch of new people they have to meet. This is Dr. Joe Degoutis. He's a cognitive neuroscientist, and he studies facial recognition. Degoutis teaches at Harvard Medical School
他们说科学作家奥利弗·萨克斯也有这种病。就是在那时，杰杰恍然大悟。所以这有点像是一种隐蔽的失调症。我的意思是，人们往往只有在不得不面对大量需要认识的新人时，才会意识到自己有这种病。这位是乔·德古蒂斯博士。他是一位认知神经科学家，专门研究面部识别。德古蒂斯在哈佛医学院任教，
and runs a lab out of the Boston VA Hospital. We've studied how people become aware that they have this, and often it's a little rocky. It's a little bit like, you know, in school, they're like, I just don't pay attention, or I don't care as much about people, or maybe I'm a little bit on the spectrum. They have all these attributions they can give.
并在波士顿退伍军人医院运营着一个实验室。我们研究过人们是如何意识到自己患有这种病的，通常这个过程有点磕磕绊绊。这有点像，你知道的，在学校里，他们会说：“我只是不太注意，”或者“我不太关心别人，”或者“也许我有点轻微的自闭症谱系障碍。”他们可以把这些表现归咎于各种原因。
The thing about people who are quote unquote face blind is that they're not actually blind. They're not seeing blurs where people's faces are. They can see eyes, nose, mouth, ears, and they can read emotions and tell whether or not someone's attractive the same way we all do. The best estimates I could find suggest that around 3% of the population has some form of face blindness. Sometimes it's the result of a traumatic brain injury, but some people are just born with it.
对于所谓“面部失认”的人来说，他们其实并不是真的看不见。当他们看到别人的脸时，并不会看到一片模糊。他们能看清眼睛、鼻子、嘴巴、耳朵，他们也能像我们所有人一样读懂情绪，分辨某人是否有吸引力。我能找到的最佳估算表明，大约3%的人口患有某种形式的面部失认症。有时这是创伤性脑损伤的结果，但有些人天生如此。
Scientists think it could be genetic, or that the network in the brain that recognizes faces just doesn't develop normally. But for most of us, a face is the trigger that calls up all the information we know about a person. If you see somebody's face, it quickly triggers the retrieval of all this other information about them, like who they are, how you know them, all these other details about the person.
科学家认为这可能是基因导致的，或者是大脑中负责识别人脸的网络没有正常发育。但对我们大多数人来说，一张脸就是一个触发器，能唤醒我们关于一个人的所有已知信息。如果你看到某人的脸，它会迅速触发对该人的所有其他信息的检索，比如他是谁、你是怎么认识他的，以及关于这个人的所有其他细节。
So it has this kind of privileged role in terms of getting all this other information out. a privileged role in terms of getting all this other information out. The clinical term for face blindness is prosopagnosia. An agnosia is an inability to recognize something. Prosopagnosia uses the Greek word for face, prosopoe, which also happens to be the Greek word for person. So much of who we are is wrapped up in this one part of our bodies. I want you to stop for a second. Think about your mom or your best friend or your
因此，在提取所有这些其他信息方面，它扮演着一种享有特权的特殊角色。在提取所有这些其他信息方面，它扮演着一种享有特权的特殊角色。面部失认症的临床术语是“prosopagnosia”。失认症（agnosia）是指无法识别某物的病症。“Prosopagnosia”的前半部分源自希腊语的面部“prosopon”，这个词恰好也是希腊语中“人”的意思。我们的自我认同有很大一部分都与身体的这个部位紧密相连。我希望你停下来一秒钟。想想你的妈妈、你的最好朋友，或者你的
kid. You're not picturing their elbows, are you? I mean, maybe you are. Crazier things have happened. My point is, for most of us, it's almost impossible to decouple who someone is from their face. It's something that is also very special about humans. This special thing that Dagoudis is talking about here has to do with our brains. We have a specific network that's just for recognizing faces, and it functions unlike any other kind of cognition. So when I recognize a chair, I'm like, oh, okay, it has something to sit on,
孩子。你脑海中浮现的肯定不是他们的手肘吧？我是说，也许真是这样。比这更疯狂的事情都发生过。我的重点是，对我们大多数人来说，将一个人的身份与他们的脸剥离几乎是不可能的。这也是人类非常独特的一点。德古蒂斯在这里谈到的这种特殊之处，与我们的大脑有关。我们拥有一个专门用来识别人脸的特定网络，它的运作方式不同于任何其他类型的认知。所以当我认出一把椅子时，我会想：哦，好吧，它有可以坐的地方，
it has some legs, and boom, it's a chair. You're recognizing things at this functional level, which is like, OK, how do I interact with this thing? You know, usually you can do it part by part. One of the things that we do with faces more than any other visual object is you process it as a gestalt as a whole, because we have to kind of recognize them and not just like, OK, that's a face, that's a face. We have to be like, okay, that's my friend. Oh, that's not that. That's so, that's the person at work who I need to avoid. And so it's like,
它有几条腿，然后——砰——它就是一把椅子。你是在这个功能层面上识别事物的，这就好比：好吧，我该如何与这个东西互动？你知道的，通常你可以通过它的各个部分来完成。我们对待面具或人脸的方式，比对待任何其他视觉物体都更独特：你会把它作为一个整体（即“完形”）来进行处理，因为我们必须认出它们，而不仅仅是像“哦，那是张脸，这也是张脸”。我们必须能够分辨：“哦，那是我的朋友。哦，那不是。那是公司里我需要躲着走的那个人。”所以这就好像是，
I think that the individuation demands of faces maybe are why we kind of have this specialized system to process faces. Frogs, you sound. Birds, you smell, and we humans love this one cluster of features sitting on top of our necks. We are social animals, and researchers think that's part of why humans developed this special recognition network in our brains. Because it served us. Faces have evolved to look really different from person to person, more so than any other body part. Scientists at UC Berkeley think that this had an evolutionary purpose. It helped us socialize.
我认为，对人脸进行个体化识别的需求，或许正是我们拥有这种专门处理人脸的系统的原因。青蛙靠声音，鸟类靠气味，而我们人类则钟爱脖子上顶着的这一团特征。我们是社会性动物，研究人员认为，这就是人类大脑中进化出这种特殊识别网络的部分原因。因为它对我们有用。人脸在进化过程中变得因人而异，差异之大超过了任何其他身体部位。加州大学伯克利分校的科学家认为，这具有进化层面的目的。它帮助我们进行社交。
Not only was it beneficial to be recognizable, but also then to be able to recognize others. Humans had to get really good at differentiating friend from foe. And we did get really good at it. Well, most of us anyways. Degoutis told me that the ability to recognize faces is a spectrum. These are all these kind of internal things that we don't talk about.
不仅能够被别人认出来是有益的，而且能够认出其他人同样至关重要。人类必须极其擅长区分朋友和敌人。而且我们确实变得非常擅长这一点。好吧，至少我们大多数人是这样的。德古蒂斯告诉我，识别面孔的能力其实是一个光谱。这些都是我们不会宣之于口的各种内在事物。
And we just assume that everybody's kind of like us, right? And after the break, we're going to the other end of that spectrum to see what it's like for the people who never forget a face. The super recognizers. One morning back in 1984, a little kid named Frank Vaughn was about to have a very exciting day of school. I was nine years old and my fourth grade class was invited on a school field trip to the governor's office in Little Rock.
我们只是理所当然地认为每个人都跟我们差不多，对吧？中场休息过后，我们将前往那个光谱的另一端，去看看那些永远不会忘记一张脸的人的世界是怎样的。超级辨识者。1984年秋天的一个早晨，一个名叫弗兰克·沃恩的小男孩即将迎来充满惊喜的一天上学时光。我当时9岁，我和四年级的同学们受邀前往小石城州长办公室进行学校的实地考察。
That's Governor Bill Clinton's office to be exact. They arranged this all in a semi-circle in cross-leg style and we waited for the man to show up. And typical of politicians, he was around 15 minutes late. He walks out, he sits down and he immediately turns and he snaps his fingers and points at one of his female staffers and said, you go get my Pepsi. And she took off on a dead run for his inner office to go grab that Pepsi. Frank was a scrawny nine-year-old boy with feathery blonde hair that grew out in all
确切地说，那是比尔·克林顿州长的办公室。他们让我们盘腿坐在一个半圆形的区域里，等待着那个男人的出现。正如政客们惯常的那样，他迟到了大约15分钟。他走出来，坐下，然后立刻转过身，打了个响指，指着他的一位女性工作人员说：“你去给我拿杯百事可乐。”那名员工立刻飞奔进他的内办公室去拿百事可乐。弗兰克当时是个瘦骨嶙峋的9岁男孩，留着一头向四面八方蓬乱生长的金色卷发。
directions. Nerdy kid, always cracking jokes for attention. Frank said that he and his classmates were so excited about meeting the governor. There was this almost throne-like velvet chair sitting in the middle of the room, and he sits down in it and he crosses his legs and he, you know, just sort of gets himself arranged. Frank remembers feeling in awe of this man sitting on a throne, barking out Pepsi orders. He said the governor greeted them all and started asking them questions.
是个书呆子气的小男孩，总是为了引起注意而讲笑话。弗兰克说，他和同学们对能见到州长感到兴奋不已。房间正中间放着一把几乎像是王座一般的丝绒椅子，他坐了上去，盘起腿，你知道的，只是稍微调整了一下姿势。弗兰克记得自己对这个坐在王座上、大声发号施令要喝百事可乐的男人充满了敬畏。他说州长向他们所有人打招呼，并开始向他们提问。
And then Clinton zeroed in on Frank. I don't know if I just have one of those faces or what, but for some reason he settled on me and he pointed at me and he said, you, what do you want to be when you grow up? And after witnessing everything I had just seen, the only answer I could come up with was, I want to be you. Frank said that his teacher looked horrified at this response. He thought he was about to get in trouble like he usually did for cracking jokes. And then the governor started laughing.
接着，克林顿把目光锁定在了弗兰克身上。我不知道是我长了一张大众脸还是怎么回事，但不知为何他挑中了我，他指着我说道：“你，长大后想做什么？”在目睹了刚刚发生的一切之后，我脑子里能想出的唯一答案就是：“我想成为你。”弗兰克说他的老师听到这个回答时露出了惊恐的表情。他以为自己又要像平时那样因为讲笑话而惹上麻烦了。然后州长笑了起来。
And of course, when he starts laughing, his staff joins in and we all joined in. And it sort of released all the tension in the room. Clinton moved on from Frank, asked some other kids questions. He lectured them about the importance of eating their vegetables and doing their homework. And then he sent the class on their way. That was that.
当然，当他开始笑的时候，他的工作人员也跟着笑，然后我们所有人都笑了。这顿时释放了房间里的所有紧张气氛。克林顿没有再关注弗兰克，而是去问了其他孩子一些问题。他告诫他们多吃蔬菜、按时完成家庭作业的重要性。然后他让这个班级解散了。事情就这样结束了。
OK, so now we're going to fast forward 13 years later, March of 1997. Clinton is just a few months into his second term as president and back in his home state of Arkansas, a series of tornadoes have just destroyed the town of Arcadelfia. Twenty five people were killed. Dozens were injured. Twelve hundred buildings were leveled. It was a huge disaster. Governor Mike Huckabee declares a state of emergency, FEMA is called in, and a few days
好了，现在我们要把时间快进13年，来到1997年3月。克林顿的第二个总统任期才刚开始几个月，在他的家乡阿肯色州，一连串龙卷风刚刚摧毁了阿卡德尔菲亚镇。25人丧生。数十人受伤。1200栋建筑被夷为平地。这是一场巨大的灾难。迈克·赫卡比州长宣布进入紧急状态，联邦紧急事务管理局（FEMA）随即介入，在风暴平息、重建工作开始几天后，
after the storm settles and the rebuilding has started, President Clinton visits Arcadelfia. It's obvious that you all have done a lot of work here in just a couple of days. Yes sir, everybody has really pitched in. Frank Vaughn is no longer a little boy. He's a 6'1 college student attending Wachita Baptist University in Arcadelfia. That feathery blonde hair is now closely cropped in the style typical of his fellow members
克林顿总统访问了阿卡德尔菲亚。显而易见，你们在短短几天内在这里做了大量的工作。是的，长官，每个人都真的全力以赴了。弗兰克·沃恩不再是个小男孩了。他是一个身高6英尺1英寸的大学生，就读于阿卡德尔菲亚的瓦奇塔浸会大学。当年那头蓬乱的金色卷发现在剪得很短，那是他预备役军官训练团（ROTC）战友们的典型发型。弗兰克和他的朋友们听说总统在镇上，于是便去碰碰运气看能不能见到他。
of the Reserve Officer Training Corps. Frank and his friends heard that the president was in town, so they went to try and see him. Frank said that there were hundreds of people lining the streets of Arcadelfia doing the same. And honestly, when I saw the entourage coming up the street with the Secret Service agents and the governor was with him, I thought, well, he's going to walk down the middle of the street because there's no way they're going to
弗兰克说，阿卡德尔菲亚的街道两侧排满了做着同样事情的数百人。老实说，当我看到随从车队带着特勤局特工沿着街道驶来，州长也和他们在一起时，我想，好吧，他肯定会沿着街道正中间走，因为他们绝不可能——
let him have, you know, physical contact with people. He's the president. And I was wrong. President Clinton, ever the people person, starts making his way into the crowd, shaking hands and taking pictures with kids. There was a limited, about a three block area that we were allowed to stand on
让他与民众有身体接触。他可是个总统。但我猜错了。克林顿总统不愧是极其擅长与民众打交道的人，他开始走进人群，与孩子们握手合影。当时我们被允许站立的区域非常有限，大约只有三个街区那么长，
from street to street to street. But he literally went up one block shaking hands, turned, went back down the next block shaking hands, turned and went back up the third block. I mean, he spent a good four hours just walking these blocks and shaking hands with people. And then Clinton gets to where Frank and his friends are standing. He stopped, stuck his hand out, shook my hand, and he looked at me and he leaned in and he said, do you still want to be me?
从这条街到那条街。但他真的是走过一个街区跟人握手，转弯，再走过下一个街区跟人握手，转弯又走回第三个街区。我的意思是，他实打实地花了整整四个小时在这些街区里散步，并与人们握手。然后克林顿走到了弗兰克和他的朋友们站立的地方。他停下脚步，伸出手，握住了我的手，看着我，身体前倾说道：“你还想成为我吗？”
Frank said that he almost passed out. There he was in the middle of a disaster zone in his college town, shaking hands with the President of the United States, who has just recalled a small anecdote from meeting him 13 years earlier, when he was nine years old and several feet shorter. The first thought in my mind was I need to go to church and pray because this is like demonic. It was just so shocking. And listen, when I tell this story, I know it's hard to believe. I understand that it seems almost impossible. But if as we say back home, if I'm lying, I'm dying.
弗兰克说他当时差点晕过去。他居然正处于大学所在小镇的灾难区中央，与美国总统握手，而这位总统竟然还记得13年的一次小型相遇——当时他才9岁，个子比现在矮好几英尺。我脑子里的第一个念头是：我得去教堂祈祷，因为这太像撞邪了。这实在是太震撼了。听着，当我讲述这个故事时，我知道这很难让人相信。我明白这听正如我们老家常说的那样，如果我在撒谎，我就不得好死。
I asked Frank how he thought Clinton could possibly have remembered him. Some people are just like that, I guess. I it's little wonder that he was, you know, born in Hope, Arkansas, to a very poor family and ended up being the most powerful man in the world. You don't get there without talent. People always talk about this mythical charisma Clinton possessed. He dazzled voters on the campaign trail. And believe it or not, there are tons of stories
我问弗兰克，他觉得克林顿怎么可能会记得他。我想有些人天生就是这样吧。难怪他出生在阿肯色州霍普镇的一个极其贫穷的家庭，最终却成为了世界上最有权势的人。没有天赋是无法达到那个高度的。人们总是在谈论克林顿身上那种近乎神话般的个人魅力。他在竞选活动中让选民神魂颠倒。信不信由你，
just like Frank's. The comedian John Mulaney has a whole bit in his 2015 comedy special about Clinton's ability to remember people. I wanna tell you one more story before I get out of here about the night I met a guy named Bill Clinton. Mulaney tells the story of this disagreement between his parents, who went to college with Clinton at Georgetown University, over whether or not Clinton would remember his mom, Ellen.
像弗兰克这样的故事还有一大堆。喜剧演员约翰·穆兰尼在他的2015年喜剧专场中，就有一整段关于克林顿认人能力的调侃。在我离开之前，我还想跟大家讲一个故事，讲的是我认识一个叫比尔·克林顿的家伙的那天晚上。穆兰尼讲述了他父母之间的分歧：他的父母当年曾和克林顿一起在乔治城大学读书，两人争论克林顿是否还记得他的妈妈埃伦。
Apparently, he would sometimes walk her home from the library in college. Mulaney talks about his mom dragging him to a campaign event in the 90s to see if the presidential hopeful still remembered their walks. Here's what happens. She was swinging me like a snowplow. I was just mowing down fat Chicago Democrats. I pushed past all the reporters. I pushed past all the photographers. We pushed past all the Secret Service.
显然，在大学里克林顿有时会送她走回宿舍。穆兰尼讲述了他在90年代被妈妈生拉硬拽到一场竞选活动现场，去看看这位入主白宫的候选人是否还记得他们当年的散步。事情是这样的。她把我像扫雪机一样推着向前。我简直是一路推倒了无数胖乎乎的芝加哥民主党人。我挤过所有的记者。我挤过所有的摄影师。我们挤过所有的特勤局特工。
We land at Bill Clinton's feet. Bill Clinton turns, looks at my mom and says, hey, Ellen, because he never forgets a bitch ever. Remember, facial recognition abilities are on a spectrum. Researchers are pretty sure it's a normal distribution with prosopagnosics on the low end. Most of you listening are probably somewhere in the normal range. But there are also these people on the very high end, the super recognizers, those who never forget a face ever.
我们来到了比尔·克林顿的脚边。比尔·克林顿转过身，看着我妈妈说：“嘿，埃伦。”因为他他妈的永远不会忘记任何人。记住，面部识别能力是存在于一个光谱之上的。研究人员非常确定它呈现正态分布，面部失认症患者处于低端。听节目的你们大多数人大概处于正常范围内。但在这个光谱的最高端，也存在着这样一群人——超级辨识者，那些永远不会忘记一张脸的人。
Something that the super recognizers are uniquely good at is being able to identify people even after a lot of time has passed or they've made changes to their appearance. This is something that Bill Clinton is very good at. Now we can't know for sure, and Bill Clinton has never said anything about this super recognizing ability, but I'd venture to say that he is almost certainly a super recognizer. Dr. Joe DeGutis, the neuroscientist, told me that one of the ways they test facial recognition abilities is by showing people pictures of celebrities when they were kids.
超级辨识者独一无二的强项在于，即使过了很长时间，或者对方的外貌发生了变化，他们依然能够认出人来。这也是比尔·克林顿非常擅长的一点。虽然我们无法百分之百确定，而且比尔·克林顿也从未公开谈论过这种超级辨识能力，但我敢说，他几乎可以肯定是一名超级辨识者。神经科学家乔·德古蒂斯博士告诉我，他们测试面部识别能力的方法之一，就是向人们展示名人童年时期的照片。
The before they were famous test. Oh, it's a picture of like, you know, Barack Obama when he was like two years old. And super recognizers can like see it. There's this kind of cool extrapolation thing that you can be like, I can see, you know, how that could be a younger version of Barack Obama. While I was reporting the story, I came across a bunch of tests online, like the before they were famous one. You can take them to gauge how good or bad you are at recognizing faces.
也就是“成名前”测试。哦，这是一张比如巴拉克·奥巴马大约两岁时的照片。超级辨识者就能一眼看出来。这种时候会产生一种很酷的推断能力，你会觉得：我能看出这怎么可能是更年轻时的巴拉克·奥巴马。在报道这个故事的过程中，我在网上看到了很多测试，比如那个“成名前”测试。你可以通过这些测试来评估自己认脸能力的好坏。
And I kept getting really good scores on them. Suddenly everything started to make sense. Remember earlier when I was telling Malcolm that I never forget people, that I sometimes feel creepy after recognizing someone in line at Target, I started to suspect that maybe I was one of these super recognizers. While J.J. misses the plot of some movies and TV shows, I get distracted by extras. Like for instance, when I notice that a passing character in a 2001 episode of Sex and the City is the guy who, spoiler alert, gets murdered in the first season of the show White Lotus 20
我的测试得分一直都很高。突然之间，一切都说得通了。还记得之前我告诉马尔colm我从不忘记别人、有时在Target超市认出人来会觉得自己像个跟踪狂吗？我开始怀疑自己可能就是这些超级辨识者之一。虽然杰杰会漏掉某些电影和电视节目的重要情节，但我却总是被路人甲分散注意力。比如，当我注意到2001年某集《欲望都市》里的一个路人甲，竟然就是20年后《白莲花度假村》第一季中——剧透警告——被谋杀的那个家伙时。
years later. Face-blind people can't find their friends on the street while I sometimes walk past someone that I recognize as my high school friend's cousin who I've only seen pictures of. In one of our early calls I told DeGutis about my theory and being the good scientist he is, he wasn't sold right away. I mean, maybe you just, like, convinced yourself that you're super and you're not really super. He needed cold, hard data, not random BuzzFeed quizzes. So I hopped on Zoom with his research assistant, Kayla Kusil, and took a three-hour battery of tests, designed to definitively say whether or not I was a super recognizer.
有面部失认症的人在街上找不到朋友，而我有时路过某人，就能认出这是我只看过照片的高中同学的表亲。在早期的一次通话中，我向德古蒂斯讲述了我的理论；而作为一名优秀的科学家，他并没有立刻全盘接受。我的意思是，也许你只是说服了自己觉得你很“超级”，但其实你并没有那么厉害。他需要冰冷坚硬的数据，而不是随随便便的BuzzFeed测试。于是我和他的研究助理凯拉·库西尔进行了Zoom连线，接受了一套长达三个小时的测试，旨在最终判定我是否是一名超级辨识者。
All right, so the next one is called Face Name. You can go ahead and click on that link. The test started off super easy. I was breezing through. So they're showing me that same face from like different angles. And I would say that is extremely easy. But things got weirder as the hours went on and I started to get a little stressed.
好的，那么下一个测试叫做“脸孔与名字”。你可以直接点击那个链接。测试一开始非常简单。我一路顺风顺水。所以他们给我看的是同一个人的脸，但角度不同。我会说这极其简单。但随着时间的推移，事情变得越来越诡异，我也开始感到有点压力。
Now I'm getting nervous. I'm like, I need to want to get these right. Which is one of the six target faces, one. I had to do things like remember jobs and names of people whose faces would flash across the screen really quickly. And at one point I was matching spiky blobs with other spiky blobs. That one was so hard.
现在我开始紧张了。我心想：我可得把这些都答对。哪个是六个目标面孔之一，1。我必须做一些诸如记住那些脸在屏幕上飞闪而过的人的职业和名字之类的事情。有一关我甚至需要把形状各异的刺状色块和另外的刺状色块进行配对。那一关太难了。
The George's is really crazy. That made me feel like I took drugs or something. I was like, whoa, what's happening here? Kayla and I wrapped up and she said they'd get back to me in a few days with my results. I was eager to hear them and unsure of what they would be. By the end I didn't think I did very well and I was kind of embarrassed about the whole charade. What if I was just average? A few days later, the verdict was in. Tagutas and I hopped on a Zoom call to go over my results. I mean you're kind of the complete package for a super recognizer.
乔治的照片实在是太疯狂了。那感觉就像我嗑了药或者别的什么。我当时想：哇，这到底是怎么回事？我和凯拉结束了测试，她说他们会在几天内把结果发给我。我很急切地想知道结果，又对结果会是什么毫无底气。到最后我觉得自己考得并不好，甚至对这一整场闹剧感到有点不好意思。万一我只是个平庸之辈呢？几天后，判决出炉了。德古蒂斯和我连线Zoom去查看我的测试结果。我的意思是，你简直是超级辨识者的完美全能组合。
So I'm kind of, I feel like, I mean, maybe when I, when you started taking the test, I was a little skeptical, but I think, I think you're, you're right on. I think this is okay. Okay. I have to admit, I was over the moon at being called the complete package. I said, please go on. Actually, looking at your results, you were like perfect on two of the diagnostic tests.
所以我有点——我觉得，我的意思是，也许当我——当你开始做测试时，我还有点怀疑，但我认为，我认为你是——完全切中要害。我觉得这很棒。好的。我必须承认，听到自己被称为“完美全能组合”时，我简直高兴得要飞上天了。我说：“请继续往下说。”实际上，看你的测试结果，你在两个诊断测试中表现得简直完美。
Like you didn't get a single item wrong. You also did really well in this very impossible task where we had you try to learn 60 faces in a very short period of time and you had to recognize them like out of 120 faces. Oh, that one was so hard. Yeah. No, you did. I mean, that's the thing.
就像你没有答错哪怕一道题。你在那个极其困难的任务中也表现得非常棒——我们让你在极短时间内尝试记住60张脸，然后你必须从120张脸中把它们认出来。哦，那一关太难了。是的。不，你做到了。我的意思是，这就是重点。
We wanted to kind of push you to see what your limits are. You do have limits, but you were really, you were really quite good. Getting my suspicions confirmed was so gratifying. It was cool to know that I have this superpower. Less than 2% of people can say the same. I had to share all of this with Malcolm. You're like the LeBron James of facial recognition. He did say it was a complete package,
我们本想借此挑战你，看看你的极限在哪里。你确实有极限，但你真的——你真的相当厉害。我的猜测得到了证实，这太让人欣慰了。知道自己拥有这种超能力，感觉真的很酷。不到2%的人能说出这话。我必须把这一切分享给马尔colm。你简直就是面部识别界的勒布朗·詹姆斯。他确实说过这是个全能组合，
so I will also take LeBron James if you want to call me that. I'm not going to argue. My experience of you is dramatically different than your experience of me. I am forced to find alternate means of recognition. What those of us who have impairment in this area do is we get obsessed with all the other possible cues that we can use to identify somebody.
所以如果你想这么叫我，我也挺乐意接受勒布朗·詹姆斯的称号。我才不会反驳呢。我对你的体验和体验我的方式截然不同。我被迫寻找其他替代性的识别手段。我们这些在这个领域有障碍的人所做的是，我们会沉迷于所有其他可以用来识别某人的可能线索。
And because they're not as reliable as the face, we're always getting into trouble. Yeah exactly this is what JJ Good, the guy from the coffee shop, told me that he tries to do too. That's Caitlin with the beautiful chin. This is Daniel. He has bald head, that's how I remember him. Small bald. So a couple months ago I spent the morning with him at the coffee shop and he was going around Introducing me to all his friends and telling me how he tries to identify them here. Oh, there she is Took me a while to recognize her but she's got like very distinct glasses, which is useful But she's been talking about changing her glasses
由于这些线索不如脸部那么可靠，我们总是陷入麻烦。没错，正是这样。咖啡馆里的那个家伙杰杰·古德告诉我，他也是这么尝试的。那是拥有漂亮下巴的凯特琳。这是丹尼尔。他是个光头，我就是这么记住他的。小光头。所以几个月前的一个早晨，我和他在咖啡馆度过了一段时光，他四处走动，把我介绍给他的所有朋友，并告诉我他是如何试着辨认他们的。哦，她在那儿。我花了点时间才认出她，但她戴着一副很有辨识度的眼镜，这很有用。不过她一直在讨论换一副眼镜，
So I'm worried about them So he told me that he tries really hard to find these cues But you know, it's it's still hard for him, and he never wants a repeat of the Missy incident. So his solution is to just treat every person that walks in as if they are his friend. Everybody who comes in the door, I stare them down because I'm like, I hope I have to see if I recognize you
所以我开始为这事担心了。所以他告诉我，他一直在努力寻找这些线索，但你知道的，对他来说这依然很难，而且他绝不想再重演米西事件。所以他的解决办法就是把每一个走进来的人都当成自己的朋友来对待。每一个进门的人，我都死死盯着他们，因为我在想：我得看看我是不是能认出你，
or know you or not. So I'm staring at them, and they look at me, and they're like, hi? And I'm like, hi, just in case I know them. And they're like, well, that guy's friendly. And that morning I was there, JJ was surrounded by people. Like you'd think he was the mayor or the owner of this place. I was like, did you tell all these people to show up because you knew I was coming? And he was like, nope. So he really has made all these friends, even in spite of the face blindness thing. And I just think that's such a lovely way to live.
还是说我认识你。所以我盯着他们看，他们看着我，然后说：“嗨？”而我就会说：“嗨”，以防万一我真的认识他们。他们就会想：嗯，这家伙还挺友好的。那天早晨我在那儿的时候，杰杰被周围的人簇拥着。你会以为他是这里的镇长或是老板。我当时问：“你是不是告诉所有人今天过来，因为你知道我要来？”而他的回答是：“没有。”所以，尽管有面部失认症，他还是交到了所有这些朋友。我觉得这真的是一种非常美好的生活方式。
That is really beautiful. JJ and Missy are great friends now, despite the incident. You can find them working and chatting at the coffee shop most days. They get dinner every once in a while, and their spouses and kids have become friends too. But their story could have ended very differently. Like, our friendship almost ended over this, and this is my nightmare. So this person felt so bad because I was not giving her the right attention that she
这真的很美好。尽管发生了那次事件，杰杰和米西现在成了好朋友。大多数日子里，你都能看到他们在咖啡馆里工作和聊天。他们偶尔会一起吃晚饭，他们的配偶和孩子们也成了朋友。但他们的故事本可能会有完全不同的结局。我们的友谊差点因此破裂，这简直是我的噩梦。所以这个人感到非常内疚，因为我当时没有给予她应有的关注，
had a whole crisis. Like, what did I do? I feel so bad. And that's why I'm so weird and extra friendly. We've all had these experiences where we don't recognize someone right away or someone doesn't recognize us. It can be embarrassing and awkward. But the split-second assumptions that we make about why, that they're aloof or that we said something that offended them
以至于她经历了一场全面的精神危机。她想：我到底做了什么？我太内疚了。这就是为什么我会表现得如此古怪且过分热情。我们都有过这样的经历：我们没有立刻认出某人，或者某人没有认出我们。这可能会让人感到尴尬和局促。但我们对于原因所做出的瞬间假设——比如觉得对方高傲冷漠，或者觉得我们说的话冒犯了他们，
or that maybe we just aren't memorable, might be wrong. Faces matter. But it all comes back to what's in our heads. Lucy? That is, you are Lucy, right? Yes, that's me. I changed my shirt, but it's still me. This has been a lot of fun. This has been great. Thanks, Malcolm. Thanks, Malcolm. History team wherever you get your podcasts. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
又或者觉得我们自己根本不值得被记住——可能都是错的。面部至关重要。但这一切最终都要回归到我们的大脑中。露西？那是——你就是露西，对吧？是的，是我。我换了件衬衫，但依然是我。这太有趣了。这太棒了。谢谢你，马尔colm。谢谢你，马尔colm。无论你在哪里收听播客，都可以订阅《Hidden Brain》。《Hidden Brain》由《Hidden Brain》传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、赖安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔担任执行制片人。我是《Hidden Brain》的执行主编。
For more Hidden Brain, be sure to check out our weekly newsletter where we bring you the latest research on human behavior. Each issue also features a brain teaser and a moment of joy. You can read it and subscribe at news.hiddenbrain.org. That's n-e-w-s dot hiddenbrain dot org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
想了解更多《Hidden Brain》的内容，请务必查看我们的每周简报，我们在其中为您带来关于人类行为的最新研究。每期还包含一个脑筋急转弯和一个快乐时刻。您可以访问 news.hiddenbrain.org 阅读并订阅。网址是 n-e-w-s dot hiddenbrain dot org。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们回头见。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。